[Music]
hello everybody have we done good
awesome fantastic welcome to a gun is
scaling multiplayer dedicated game
servers with kubernetes I hope this is
the session you expected this is where
you're staying hopefully for Lola my
name is Mark Randall I'm a developer
advocate for Google cloud specializing
in games and I guess technically founder
of this project I think he's probably
accurate so we're gonna talk today about
multiplayer games criminy teas
containers and other good stuff in that
kind of arena that sounds cool sounds
good
awesome I regularly give this talk at
game conferences so this is probably one
of the first times I've actually given
it to a wider tech event so I'd like to
know a little bit more about you so I
know my audience and I can tailor
appropriately so people here who work in
the games industry actually more than I
expected that's cool awesome so people
who work on like specifically on
multiplayer games most the same hand
alright awesome cool alright so very
many of you who don't that's totally
cool is fine we're gonna look at some of
that to people who are comfortable with
docker most of you but not all that's
fine to people who are comfortable with
kubernetes also not all of you that's
also cool too all right sweet that
actually gives me that gives me a really
good idea of where we want to take this
and where we want to go excellent
so what are we talking about today so
the thing I want to talk today is about
multiplayer games and multiplayer games
is a broad and far-reaching term but I
wanna talk about very particular types
of multiplayer games what I want to talk
about is your very competitive online
fast paced multiplayer games right so
your Unreal Tournament your ever watches
your fortnight's your mmo's your rocket
leagues games like that all right
things we're very fast-paced things
happen between the players and they have
very particular needs and we're gonna
talk about how we sort of cater towards
those sort of needs with a project like
the conus to do that I'm gonna use an
open source project called zoonotic
anyone here played or heard of synodic
that is like the first hand I've ever
i've ever go up so that's awesome very
happy it's a really cool open-source
game that has very traditional like FPS
type gameplay so i capture the flag
deathmatch things like that but it's
great it's open source so we're gonna
use that as a demonstration of how we
can use that on taganas for playing and
scaling most player games it sound cool
cool so as you saw in the title I use
this term dedicated game server so for
those of you who aren't in the games
industry there's maybe something you
haven't heard of before so let's talk
about what that actually means so there
are a variety of ways of making these
types of multiplayer games one of the
most prevalent ways especially amongst
very large-scale games is about what's
called doing a dedicated game server so
a dedicated game server is a full
simulation of the game that you're
playing so like all the physics all the
interactions between the players and all
the people who are playing said game
interact or directly connect to that
dedicated game server so usually they're
sending things like hey I'm moving
forward please let me move forward
hey I'm rocketing cuz I'm firing a
rocket car or something maybe I'm firing
a gun maybe I'm doing all sorts of
actions and I tell the dedicated game
server what it is that I want to have
happen that dedicated game server then
will then actually simulate what's
happening inside that system and then
pass out what's true and what's
happening from that dedicated game
server back to the clients so they can
render it to the people who are playing
that game there's a couple of very good
reasons for doing this one of which is
latency so games that are very fast
paced 10 minutes 10 milliseconds 20
milliseconds 30 milliseconds of latency
can be a very big deal
so having control over exactly
geographically where these dedicated
game servers are sitting in relation to
the players that are playing playing
them gives you a lot of control and
gives you a player experience that you
can rely on and this is a good thing
right we can't control the speed of
light it'd be really nice if we could um
so having that that geographic location
based system is really really nice to
the players on top of that um I might
let you in on a little secret I don't
know if you've noticed this but some
people are really horrible I don't know
I maybe you haven't noticed I don't know
maybe that's great and if you haven't
that's wonderful but as soon as you hand
someone a binary with traffic they can
incre introspect people tend to do that
they tend to have a look at what
traffic is they tend to have a look at
the binary they try and play with it and
mess around with it basically they try
and cheat having a dedicated game server
that sits on your own network can
mitigate some aspects of that to which
so that gives you some leg up in that
way as well we're not gonna talk about
that much but it's something to consider
so dedicated game servers are good and
because they a mitigate cheating right
the idea is that their authority they
are the source of truth about what is
happening inside a game I say that I
shot that person over there it is the
dedicated game servers job to say hey
that actually happened in the way that
you expected it to the way I like to
think of it is each of the client asks
to do something on the dedicated game
servers job is to tell alright this is
actually what's happening so cool we
have a bit of an idea about dedicated
game servers and how they work awesome
so traditionally how are these things
architected so you might have say in a
typical like session based game like say
somebody's playing like capture the flag
or something like that you might have
two more people who are like I want to
play a game so I sort of declare they
want to play a game and they're gonna
talk to some kind of matchmaker that
matchmaker is probably gonna pair them
based on skill level maybe their social
graph stuff like that and once they've
got a pairing or a match for some kind
they're gonna talk to some kind of
server manager this server managers job
is basically to be like hey you need a
game server to run on and then you can
all connect to so it'll then talk to you
a potentially very large cluster of
machines potentially spanning the globe
be like okay this machine's the good
machine awesome we like this one it's
got enough resources sweet let's spin up
a process on it let's set up the game
server we'll find the port that's free
fantastic all right so now we have an IP
import we're like these games they've
been playing it on now we can send that
back up the pipe all the way up through
the matchmaker to those two players and
they can make a direct connection to the
game right direct connection to your
important because latency right we don't
want to go through a load balancer also
of that full simulation stated in there
right so we can make direct connections
and everything that happens inside that
machine so that's basically how a lot of
very traditional big multiplayer FPS you
know very fast-paced games work the pot
that I want to talk to them about today
though is this pot here this is where a
ganas kind of comes in right so we're
not talking about like the matchmaker
but what we're talking about is the
system that says oh I need a game server
but we're in this cluster should I put
it where should I run it right back
kind of stuff how do I spin it up how do
I spin it down that kind of thing and
this is really the kind of problem that
a gun is is trying to solve so I - what
we're talking about although apparently
if I say it right it should be a harness
we should have a rolling R I've been
told by people who say Greek so this is
an open source project that technically
we started back in November that we only
announced it earlier this year for that
is well for running scaling hosting
dedicated game servers for multiplayer
games I'm pretty excited about it and I
think it's really cool so I'm glad that
you all came here to hang out with me
today to hear all about it the thing
that's really cool about this as well we
aren't doing this alone so this is a
Google cloud LED project except for the
fact that we are doing it with a
wonderful collaboration with Ubisoft
they've really brought to the table
their long-term experience in running
multiplayer games at scale and they've
been doing it for a real long time and
is from the title as you see we've been
building this on top of crouppen Eddie's
we've been able to build the experience
we have with running containers and
building kubernetes and it's been a
really lovely like meeting of minds I
feel like they're lovely people and I
can't say enough nice things about them
actually sweet
so let's actually get into how does this
thing work and we'll look at some code
and how do we actually make this thing
happen and stop talking to your reticle
and get actually practical that's not
cool yeah awesome so um tential e
unsurprisingly we're going to talk about
containers so we reuse a lot of what
creepy entities gives us out of the box
so first step for taking our dedicated
game server right so say we've we've
written a dedicated game server maybe
we've done it ourselves if use unity
we've used unreal really the first step
is basically we put it inside a
container there's nothing really special
going on here but I want to talk about
containers for a bit - especially those
people who aren't familiar with it so if
you if you haven't really worked with
the container as much the part that I
find most exciting and the part that I
think is most relevant here as well is
that really containers are a standard
all right they enable you to take a set
of software and build an artifact that
is transportable that is runnable all
through a standard set of interfaces so
we use this analogy a lot of like an
actual shipping container but I feel
it's really apt right so it doesn't
matter whether I'm running a game server
running Internet or a C++
or node I don't care it's in a container
that's great in the same way with the
shipping container I don't care if it's
a Ferrari or a whole bunch of chairs or
I don't know tablecloths I can pick it
up with the same cranes I can put you on
the same truck I can put it you know in
the same ships everything is fine as
long as it fits that standard and so
this is true here too but because we can
put our game server inside a container
we can put whatever we want inside it
whatever systems you need inside it this
is our basic building block and it means
that we can do very generic stuff with
it that we need to do for both game
servers as much as we would for any
other types of software how do I get new
versions of it how do I get my logs out
of it how do I know if it's running
right these are all standard problems
for everybody so to prove to you that
I'm not like twisting your arm or
anything this is essentially the docker
file for running stenotic if you haven't
written darker files before they're
fairly imperative there have a series of
commands we do them you start from the
top most of many of you have done this
so this is probably not new for you we
start from the top so we say hey let's
start from Debian to start from a Linux
instance and then we download stenotic
and we move some files around basically
sinaitic requires us to put in this
server Linux toad SH in the right spot
so it'll run as a dedicated game server
instead and then we set an entry point
which basically says when you've created
an image from this docker file and you
run it run this thing there's nothing
really special here I just want to be
clear about this um I am slightly
hand-wavy I'll admit this up front if
people have actually worked with
organize there is an SDK that is built
into iguanas for doing standard game
server lifecycle things it's one of the
things that gives you out of the box so
hey this game servers ready health
checks things like that I'm gonna be
hand-wavy about that here we actually do
some wrapping stuff first a nutty
because I don't want to touch the code
fine but that does exist but essentially
here this is just a docker container
there's nothing special here we're not
removing any capabilities we're not
adding anything it's just it's just a
standard docker container so anything
you can put in here so again for those
who honours familiar with docker once we
have this docker file we're able to
create a docker image right this is
something we can tag we can version and
then we can share this around with a
registry if you're not
Ducker again this is the thing to let
you do hey this is a new version I want
this to go out live who can grab a copy
of this if I download this image is it
the right image is it the run that I
expect it to be that kind of stuff so
all that stuff that you have when you're
like oh I have a game server I would
like to update it those sort of problems
are essentially solved just by using the
standard tool so nothing too special
there in the Agana slam but I just want
to set a kind of baseline and that kind
of that duck or knowledge so to prove to
you that it works if I can switch to
demo please thank you very much I'm
gonna run my server so I'm I'm actually
running we're talking about the SDK I'm
actually running the local version of
the SDK here so I'm just gonna run this
from here but to prove to you like
docker run that's anodic running I know
that doesn't look like much but I just
want to be really clear about something
I didn't like run the specific commands
I needed to care about for cinetic I
just ran docker run and that's really
powerful right that's the abstraction
I'm talkin about that's really nice
because as long as I run docker run I
server runs everything is good that
makes me happy cool so that's like super
baseline docker stuff but from a game
server perspective we can switch back to
the slides that'd be awesome thank you
okay so we have a game server probably
we integrated the SDK which is great we
put inside a container alright nothing
too special but we don't want just for
players we want lots of players lots of
players good for some reason only having
one player or two players doesn't pay
the bills I don't know why but II mean I
said we had lots and lots of players so
this is where we step into the land of
Krupa Nettie's so you've probably heard
this sweat a lot being here at Google
cloud next it's not surprising if you're
not familiar with this at all which is
totally fine think about it the most
simplest way I can ever explain
kubernetes is that it is an open source
project for running processes over
thousands of machines or even less just
over big clusters of machines if this
sounds familiar compared to like what
word is we're talking about there's a
reason for that
kubernetes is really important to a
gona's and I want to talk about it for a
couple of reasons one because it's kind
of an
and what it's available to you to do
because out of the box it gives you
things like hey I want to run these
processors I want to run ten of them
make sure they're off make sure they
stay up let me do log aggregation lots
of really good stuff to straight up the
Box the big thing that's really
important about creeping eddies and why
it's important as well for games and
game servers is it is an open standard
for basically running infrastructure so
you might comment out of the gate and
you're like awesome I'm gonna run my
game servers on top of a ghana's and
we're gonna stick it on gke and it's
gonna be awesome all right we're gonna
use Google cloud and it's great and then
you discover that in some pocket of the
world you have a really fervent player
base and then you're like oh well
criminalities is great but gke doesn't
seem to cover it let's look at some
other cloud providers maybe they do
maybe they don't
and you're like you know what would be
great it would be great if I could just
set up a little Colo somewhere like buy
some hardware put my game servers there
because then they're gonna have the best
game experience they can have because
latency matters so wouldn't it be great
if I just had a platform where I could
basically pick this up and put this
wherever I want this is what croute
minetti's gives us which is amazing
right so criminais these are the
standards you might come to us and be
like GK is great awesome but sometimes I
also want to run on my own hardware
right maybe I want to run GK on Prem
that's pretty cool
I'm really excited about that by the way
or maybe I just want to be able to put
it you know in two particular places so
once you have cribben eddie's that means
that you can run argona is on top of it
and yeah that gives you the flexibility
to run your workload for your games and
your game servers in exactly the right
place they didn't make sense for your
players and that gets me really excited
too because that means we can all play
better games which I like playing games
I learn about you that makes things fun
so let's look at how this works the
other part of what crew Bonetti gives us
as well is some really amazing abilities
to extend it all right so there's people
who are familiar with kubernetes you've
probably seen like deployments you've
seen services you've seen pods like
you've seen these sort of nouns of
things that exist inside kubernetes and
you get into the world of what's called
custom resource definitions and
controllers which is a term if you want
to completely forget that's totally fine
you get into this realm where you're
able to add your own nouns to kubernetes
and tell it how to handle them all right
so it knows how to handle web server
type experiences you do a deployment run
ten of them if one of them dies don't
care
but what we want is we want an
experience that works for Game Servers
we want to be like hey fire up this game
server but let me know when like it's
ready to accept player connections
that's something I care about
make sure there's health checking that
makes sense for a game server right
before players have connected you can
restart that's okay but once players are
connected don't restart because
otherwise weird stuff can happens when
players can reconnect to game servers
that have zero state like that's all
weird so stuff like that right so we're
able to extend kubernetes both from a
llamó perspective but it also extends
the backing API as well so I'm gonna do
a bunch of stuff here as well
we've gone is that we're gonna use
Hamill which is the pretty standard way
of doing stuff with kubernetes but
anything you've seen me doing with the
Apple and cube CTL I can do through an
API as well I can do it all through the
creep entities API so just keep that in
mind anyway so if we want to fire up a
game server right in this case the
sinaitic game server how do I do that
once I've installed Logan is I can
create this thing called a game server
it's really that simple how does that
work so I say game server I can give it
a name I can also tell creeper Nettie's
to create it generate a game server name
for me if I want that's just part of
communities and then I've got very game
server specific things like what ports
do you want to open on this so that I
can connect to it now we do direct
connections with dedicated game servers
that's no sudden the Kuban Eddie's gives
you out of the box this is something
that agonies will handle for you
so we'll do allocation reports for you
so that you don't have to worry about
that yourself when we do that port
routing as well for you make life nice
and easy
so we do port management give you
multiple ports and then we can do a set
of containers all right so here this is
the game server container stenotic 0.34
those of you who are more familiar with
kubernetes what's available here is
actually a full pod spec as well so
anything you can do with a pod you can
do inside organize as well so if you
wanted to like volume mounts secret
mounts config management all that stuff
that's all available multiple multiple
containers et cetera cetera for those of
you not so familiar don't worry about it
you can run a container so here we're
running the Cintiq example tag running
out of the Google Cloud registry here
instead and so this gives us the ability
to run a game server so if we can switch
back over to demo let's run one so that
sound like fun awesome
so here I have up top
we've scope which is a great
visualization I'm gonna win stall
organized first we have a helmet art for
that although you can use an install
Amal let's see if I get this right home
stole name equal so Ghana's name space
equals system cool install how am I
gonna I think I got that right so it
should spit back a whole bunch of stuff
see my internet works good that actually
looks right that's good it should show
me a controller at some point soon
Gowanus well something happen there we
go okay so that's that's up and running
so that's basically me and stalling ago
knows that's it's not particularly
complicated alright pretty
straightforward which is quite nice and
now everything is available to me to run
a game server so let's just have a look
at pods here I'm gonna go into the
default namespace which is where I'm
gonna create my game server again
everything so I'm just gonna do a cutesy
tale apply so this is going to apply the
game server configuration we saw
previously
that's what am i doing I'm doing example
study and I wanted to run as a game
server demo so we now have a game server
that's been created you'll see that says
the word game server there
if I actually what's really cool if
you've never looked at any of this
extension stuff I can say get game
server for example and it understands
what game server is I can even describe
this this is going to show a bunch of
stuff I came server and it'll give me a
code completion as well which is also
should be nice but I'm not gonna look at
that right now so we can see that
cinetic stunning if we want to we can
have a look at its logs there's a bunch
of stuff happening great I can see
there's there's a bunch of messages
coming out so that's all up and running
which is lovely
there's a if I describe I can see
there's a bunch of events we get a bunch
of status data oh my god that's really
hard to see okay so we're not gonna do
it that way um here's a cute thing that
I really like anyone use cube CTL and
get custom like columns I really like
this can do your and keep CTL commands
and give you custom homes so this gives
us a really nice thing so when we fired
up a game server so nobody's gonna fire
it out allocated a port so we messed up
multiple ports so it comes out as a map
and it'll give us the IP address and
it'll give us a status as well right
when a game server is ready it marks
itself is ready so it's good to go so
that's cool we can fire up a game server
that's pretty neat it gives us an IP
import we can see that it's running but
we can do more than this so let's
actually delete this game server jess is
just the shorthand for game server we'll
come back over to the slides we come
back over to the slides thank you
excellent okay so we can do more but
let's just have a quick look so we saw
the previous architecture riot we were
like couple players who want to play
with a matchmaker right so maybe we have
a custom matchmaker possibly the new
open-source matchmaker that's coming out
later this year that'd be cool that
we're doing um
and instead of talking to some server
manager we instead talk to the
kubernetes api i make it say kubernetes
api please create me a game server and
cribben ed is a declarative like this
which is nice too right so we tell her
what we want and it goes ahead and does
it
we would like a game server create one
for me please and it'll do that it'll
create a dedicated game server send back
the IP import we can send that back up
the pipe and our friends can play again
but like I said we can do more sometimes
in fact often times we don't want to
fire these up one at a time what we want
to do instead is have a large group of
them right so very much like if you use
creep energies before instead of having
like just individual pods what we really
want is an employment so what we have
instead is we also have the what's
called a fleet so hey I would like to
have a pool of 100 game servers please
set it all up and ready and then when
the player wants to play with them I
would like you to pull one out of the
fleet and hand it over to me and then I
can set players to play games so that I
don't have to wait that would be sweet
and then I can keep track of what's in
the fleet and I know what my players are
doing and everything's good
there's another cool stuff that we'll
look at in here too so if you've ever
played with um deployments this probably
looks fairly familiar this is just
another extension so we have a fleet it
looks like a game server except we just
specify how many replicas we want and
then we specify what we want a game so
every two look like so here we have two
and we have a game server that looks
pretty much exactly as it was before
nothing really different other than
we're specifying that we want lots of
them cool but you may be asking a very
interesting question which is a good
question indeed we don't have load
balancers right how do we pull a game
server out from this set and be like I
would like one of these please can I
have one please so we have a thing
called a fleet allocation this is just
one way you can do this we have a full
API so you can do a whole bunch of
different different types of workflows
just so it's clear but this is what we
we prefer at least right now so we are
but to say hey
cribben Eddie's give me a fleet
allocation out of this particular fleet
and it's gonna respond with a game
server that's actually marked as
allocated as well this is quite nice so
it'll do all the management of those
game servers be able to look through
them all and be like hey let's see if
there's one that's ready and available
and waiting for you and if there is it's
gonna pull it out and be like cool I'm
gonna mark that it's allocated and then
I'm gonna give that back to you now
allocated is special and we'll look at
that in a minute
let's yeah let's head let's head over to
demo land again and we'll play some more
excellent so let's let's fire up a fleet
so we can just have a quick look at it
we'll apply F examples fleet and this is
basically exactly what we had before so
I'm gonna create two instances of this
game server we'll see they come up
relatively fast which is nice if we run
that command that we were running
previously we can see there's two of
them they're ready they're running on
different ports they're running on the
same node that's fine that's cool okay
and we can do very similar things to
what we had previously
like for example sorry now we have
previously but if you use deployments
for example we can edit our fleet it's
called synodic I'm gonna be like let's
make that bigger
if we were like hey I would actually
like ten we can make that happen
for those more familiar with tripping
Eddie's at some point in the near future
we'll make it so you can keep CTL scale
that'll happen but we've asked for ten
oh here we go yep and there's a whole
bunch of them getting created so we can
scale these up and down which is really
nice but let's allocate and look of a
look at exactly what happens when we
start allocating stuff out so we'll have
a quick review so let's run this command
so we can see there already that's good
we have 10 of them sweet so let's
allocate so this is something you might
you would probably end up doing through
a API command so you probably allocate
from your matchmaker and be like hey
give me one so I have people who can
play a game for me I'm just gonna show
it to you with the ammo if you ever want
to get the results out of ammo let's do
that it'll spit it back out of here it's
gonna spit out a lot of stuff at this so
actually let's make that bigger so
that's because I wrote the wrong thing
that's fine we're running demos it's fun
app we want to create this okay so I've
got that's fine we want to explicitly
create it let's do that okay that's
better
all right so this is spitting back all
of the stuff oh my god so much so I'm
gonna ignore most of it spinning it back
we'll see we have a status it gives us
back a game server right here but the
bit that I care about really is this bit
down here at the bottom where I say
status right so it's giving me back the
game server so we looked at that before
when I ran the command it gives us an IP
address it gives us the port and it
gives us a state allocated this is kind
of the big thing I think we've gone is
and we've game servers is kind of the
tricky part about it we sort of talked
about it before right so before players
connect to a game we don't care about
that game server so I could scale this
fleet down to zero and it would kill all
of them because there's no players
connected and that's great but as soon
as were allocated we're assuming that
there are players connected right now
and you do not want to delete that game
server because for some silly reason
players get mad when you cut off their
game halfway through so let's try not to
make that happen this is one of the big
things I think is gone is really gives
us so let's actually
we're gonna we're gonna let's allocate a
whole bunch and I'll prove to you that
I'm not 100 cent line okay so sweet you
can see we have four allocated for
example what happens at this point if we
want to scale back down at this point
right so if we want to keep CTL edit our
fleet again what is it called synodic
there we go we want to bring this down
to three that's gonna take a little
while because those game servers take a
little while to shut down what if we
right actually look at the pods which is
like the backing containers that are
running we'll see that most of them are
terminating right so these things are
shutting down but we still have four
that are running even though we've told
that we want to go down to two it's
gonna go down to four and this also
applies for when you want to do updates
as well so fleets manage updates for you
as well we're going to look at that
today but say I want to have a whole new
version of a game server and I want to
roll that out I can do that I can do a
cube CCL edit or we do apply of a new
version mix etc usual stuff and it'll go
cool we're gonna have any version come
through excellent so it'll stop pushing
that version through but the game
servers that are currently connected and
are allocated it's gonna leave them
alone until they shut themselves down so
this is really important stuff and kind
of different from how a lot of other
applications work so if we have a look
here again cool we can start to see like
this is starting to disappear but we
still have those allocated servers and
they're never gonna go away until we're
finished okay let's play a game like
that's kind of what we here for right
video games are fun so let's grab one of
these not the unhealthy one that would
be bad here we go let's grab the top one
actually don't you do that I've got the
IP address here so I got an IP address
here for one of these on a port and
there's a port open on seven seven nine
one so pop over here run this okay
that's gonna pop up out we'll turn that
off because that's just distracting yeah
the other fun question is I can't see my
IP in port
that's hilarious I didn't think of that
anyway that's mine
3:51 97.1 97.1 s over again one i-74
2.36 so let's type that right nope one
97.48 do this well okay that's fine
QC Joe describe game server synodic
it'll put it this will put it on the
Left HD 8 there we go okay there we go
yeah I can just scroll up a little
perfect I have done this once where I
actually took a photo of it and then did
it that way and it was it worked it was
fine three 5.19 7.4 2.3 six seven seven
nine one all right
litmus test will this work black screen
is actually good I don't know why they
made the game that way just to give me a
heart attack so this is connecting to a
gke server so we like I said we ran and
we ran a fleet it's fired it up it's
found a port for it it's allocated to a
particular node in the cluster here we
go and giving us a game server its
allocated itself is ready and now I have
to play on my trackpad and fine come on
there's there like four other BOTS in
here somewhere
do you know something I don't think I've
actually played on this level before I'm
playing come on just show me another
player all I want is like one other
player somewhere in here of course I
can't find a single soul literally as
soon as I'm in front of a whole group of
people there we are but there we go yeah
all right so here we are we're playing
we're playing so this is me running a
ghana's on a cluster on gke that's
somewhere around here on the east coast
or the west coast and so it actually
works
cool cool so that's it actually working
which is also cool - awesome okay so
let's move back to the slides again
please fantastic okay so this is this is
kind of cool this means that we have a
very similar architecture to what we
were looking at previously with just
spinning up game servers but now we have
a warm fleet
which is really nice so that means then
when we run this thing we can say to a
ganas hey we have this fleet give me one
of these out of this fleet and it'll
pull and out of the fleet for me with
the appropriate locking and the
appropriate atomicity and we can send
that information back up and these
people can play a game as well but the
nice thing here and I kind of want to
highlight it as well is these are layers
on top of layers right so if in the same
ways with cribben eddie's if you're like
I like pods but I don't want to deal
with deployments for whatever reason or
you want to do something very specific
we can do stuff if you're like I don't
like the way fleets work you can
interact directly with game servers or
you could you can manipulate fleets and
some very interesting ways as well so
we're trying to build that flexibility
in you can do some really neat things so
where are we going in the future with
this thing right we're we're so
technically today I was meant to put out
the zero point 3.0 release because
that's where it is in the calendar next
kind of got in the way a little bit I
shouldn't it should happen
it should happen today I think maybe but
the 0.34 no RSC candidate came out last
week so we're on a six-week
rotating really cycle so that's working
out really nicely so the next we have a
bunch of stuff coming the next big
ticket items statistic collection and
display so we wanted to very standard
stuff like player count how many game
servers how many play like game servers
we had over time so but we also want to
do very game server specific statistic
collection and display as well all right
so framerate hitching right so we want
to be able to look at exactly what those
are very very particular things do you
want we want to have those baked in
because basically everyone needs these
things we're gonna look at auto scaling
order scaling has some very unique and
interesting problems to game servers as
well that are very different from other
things as we look before you can't
shutdown modes with people playing games
they get mad so we need to look at that
and there's some also some interesting
statistical stuff that we can play with
there we want to have some better
commercial engine integrations so we've
got a lot of interest specifically
around unreal as well for doing this and
we're actively working on that right now
we've got SDKs for C++ for go for rust
which actually got dropped by the other
day which was really cool but we've also
opened it up now the whole SDK system is
built on G RPC but we've opened it up to
rest as well so if you can send either G
RPC or I should be Jason you can build
an integration it's pretty straight
forward which is quite nice
we are actively looking at Windows
hosting so Windows is pretty big in the
games industry strangely enough so
there's been some wonderful work by a
lot of people who were doing work with
kubernetes and windows that we're
looking to rely on so we want to make
sure that that's that's as well
supported as we can make it as well
finally all the way down the line we
definitely want to be supporting multi
cluster I think multi cluster is the
group that does a lot of the multi
cluster work so we want to make it easy
and available for you to run multiple
clusters around the globe we also want
to build tooling into that as well so
like one of my ping times from these
clusters are these clusters are
available be able to take them down so
you can do that round-trip time so you
know what your latency ZAR between the
clusters again just standard stuff that
people people are gonna need cool so
what are we what did we do today just to
kind of wrap things up in a nice pretty
bow so we took our dedicated game
servers alright we were talking about
that right we don't care what language
they're in right as long as they can
interact with our SDK which pretty much
everything can which is great we stuck
them inside a container so we're good
right you can put whatever you want in
there which is great it gives you the
flexibility to do pretty much whatever
you need with your dedicated game server
then we took that container and we stuck
it on top of organize which is nice so
now we can scale this right we can scale
this out to thousands of machines we can
run thousands of game servers so we can
support lots and lots and lots and lots
of players which is good because lots of
players they like spending money which
is good if you want to learn more
agon a start dev will take you directly
to the github repository we should have
a fancy new website and maybe about a
month or so we're working on that too I
got any dev on Twitter as well we've got
a mailing list we've got a very active
reasonably active slack channel where we
like to talk about this stuff a lot
we are definitely actively looking for
crunch reproduce in any way shape and
form so if you're interested come into
slack and just be like hey I'd like to
help that'd be great
for obvious reasons if you're interested
in kubernetes kubernetes Ohio etc and
that kind of stuff as well um I don't
know if you noticed I weigh this t-shirt
it says something like Google cloud
platform podcast so if you were miss if
I didn't take the opportunity like
spooks out a little so if you find me at
least vaguely entertaining myself am
Melanie Warwick run a podcast go Google
cloud platform podcast where we talk
about all sorts of things cloud
including game stuff and sort of the
Kuban Eddy stuff machine learning also
their stuff along those lines as well I
will really write reiterate if you do
have questions and you don't get to them
today my business cards are sitting
right there so please feel free to come
up and grab some and come swing by my
dm's or if it on Twitter you can hit me
up on email anything like that so if you
don't think of anything at this
particular point in time I'm open and
interested in hearing your opinions and
questions finally thank you very much
for coming and hanging out with me today
I know your time is valuable and I
appreciate you decided to spend it with
me so thank you very much
you
[Music]